will the push to alice newsome prove to
be successful let's ask the woman
who was part of the golden state's 2003
governor gray davis recall tammy bruce
tammy happy new year to you thanks for
joining us
same to you my pleasure great way to
start the new year
it is indeed and i think this is a story
that's really going to gain steam now
since uh 1911 i believe it is 55 times
californians have tried to
recall their governor but only once was
it successful
you were a part of it in 2003 in
recalling
governor davis of course we got arnold
schwarzenegger out of it
what do you see in parallels between
then and now
well that was a real populist effort it
was obviously thousands of people
involved in organizing uh but it it
the similar thing is of course the
people of the southwest the people of
the west of this country
really still are revolutionaries we all
are at heart right it's in our dna
but i think that what californians while
all americans are
are generally of course tolerant we're
quiet people
is that what they don't like is
unfairness they don't like being lied to
none of us do
and that's what gavin newsom did that's
what grade davis was doing to the to the
state as well
also negative impact on on the the
economy
so this is really a nonpartisan issue so
i think that they can have success i
certainly hope they do
uh schwarzenegger was not a success so
my
only warning is when you do this recall
is make sure
that there's a lot of thought put into
who it is that's being encouraged to run
there are over 60 people by the way
griff who who ran for governor
on the same ballot as the recall in
2003.
it was a fabulous experience it was a
nonpartisan race
and we know that the process worked well
but i think that this is a warning to
everyone it's it's the economy
the handling of covid uh the the
corruption
this lobbyist guy uh californians don't
like it and i think they'll be
successful
and it's fascinating in 2003 of course
davis was dealing with an
energy crisis his failures there led to
the recall
now we have newsome in his failures in
handling
covet 19. how close though is this
to actually succeeding teaming because
we know you need a million and a half
signatures
they've got a little over 800 thousand
we just saw our first irvine based
consulting firm give a half a million
dollars
to this effort how likely is it to
succeed
well the the campaign itself is noted on
social media that
a lot of that money that we've heard
these big donations which are good
are not in cash somehow and they need
paid circulators that's what our
experience was in 2003
that the populist base uh the grassroots
base is great in distributing
but you need an organized paid
circulator framework
money is needed uh this can be done but
they're still they don't want people to
think that that big news about this
great support
uh is it makes it done it's not done uh
we have to start they have until march
that's not a lot of time
and we've got to get this done it is the
very least that
that americans can pull off and we've
done it before uh and so keep that in
mind but
they can do it they need to get past the
one and a half million of course because
some of those signatures won't be good
and they realize that but it certainly
is a doable uh framework
and tammy just in the time we've got
about 30 seconds left
how important is it raising questions
about
the governor's ties to this lobbyist
kinney that he was at
his 50th birthday party at the french
laundry
yeah well you know i equate corruption
with being like a bag of potato chips
you don't do it just once
right you keep going in this case it's
like a a pile of trash
uh you don't dig through the trash to
find the sweet-smelling roses there's
more underneath
he lied when he ran for office about the
death penalty as an example
he's been a failure at governing and now
you've got a guy who's been with him for
at least
14 years who ghost writes his speeches
who was
a part of this french laundry dinner and
a part of so much more
the question is and the concern is that
that gavin newsom
is doing things that benefit that
lobbyist and those
interests as opposed to benefiting the
people of california
and how do you know because the people
of california
are in dire straits and gavin newsom and
his friends are not
terry bruce kicking off 2021 with a
great line
it's so true you can't just eat one
potato chip thanks tammy
that's right